to other news now and the president of
Suriname has been sentenced to 20 years
in prison from murder
Dessie booter c was convicted of killing
15 political opponents in 1982 the
courts ruled that battersea oversaw an
operation to have them abducted and
killed
now he's currently out at the country on
an official trip to China the military
court that found him guilty on Friday
has not ordered his arrests ants the
president can appeal the sentence a
bitter see led Suriname through the
1980s as heads over military government
the court ruled that during this time he
was in charge of an operation which
lawyers in which lawyers journalists and
university professors were seized from
their homes and killed but one
individual survived the attack I can
testified before the trial which began
some 12 years ago battersea and his
supporters have repeatedly tried to stop
the proceedings they even passed a law
to grant him immunity a law which was
later invalidated now in 1999 a Dutch
courts convicted the president in
absentia on drug trafficking charges
charges that the tarsi has denied let's
get more on this story Bruce Merrin
hafte is the proof is a professor of
history of Suriname at the University of
Amsterdam and joins us now on skype from
Amsterdam itself kids have you with us
on the program this is a rather unusual
case as at Knossos the sort of thing
that we'd bring down in any other
leaders so given this do you think this
is the end for Battersea thank you for
having me I'm not sure this is going to
be the end of about at least not yet he
has been very cunning in staying in
power he has been the most powerful man
in Suriname arguably since 1980 behind
and before the scenes and I think he is
coming back tomorrow he will be landing
according to plan at 4:00 a.m. in the
morning and his party has called
to receive him and bring him and triumph
to the capital and so I guess we'll be
waiting to see what happens when he
comes back for China but it's unusual is
it not that the military haven't issued
a warrant for his arrest even though he
has been found guilty of these crimes
how would you explain that I think the
judges in this case all female by the
way where are afraid of a civil unrest
or maybe even a civil war type situation
so they don't want to go too far and you
have to remember that Bao - sir despite
all these allegations has never been a
day in jail or has been arrested before
nor has he testified in court and well
if the the the military were perhaps
afraid of civil unrest arising from this
does this suggest that the the president
enjoys quite widespread popular supports
because these aren't quite staggering
charges orchestrating a campaign of
rounding up 15 of your political
opponents noting the murders as there is
there is the country split on this case
or or does the presidents enjoy quite a
loss of support I think it's safe to say
that the country is split on this a case
he has support he has a very well
organized party he is the president he
is elected democratically and you
shouldn't forget sir nom first of all as
a small country less than 600,000 people
live there and secondly many of these
inhabitants are young they were not
there they were not born yet
when these December killings in 1982
happened so they don't have an active
memory so they're addressed is split
about people being for or against
partisan but also younger people who
just have no memory of this and just
finally what does this case say about
democracy and the rule of law in
Serena well it is a triumph act I think
for the rule of law
and that justice can be done this has
taken very long you mention its it
started in 2007 it was even a pre-trial
before that so this has been more than
12 years in the making so this is a
triumph for the state of law okay Rose
Marin Huff's I'm afraid we'll have to
leave it there but great to get your
thoughts and analysis on this case
rustling often joining us live from
Amsterdam thank you